[Music]
it's about to get Old Testament here
what if the creepiest karolius most
catastrophic member of the plagues of
Egypt made an unexpected house call and
decided your city was next on the dinner
menu that's right
a locusts swarm has arrived how much
damage would it do and is there any way
to stop it this is what if and here's
what would happen if a massive locust
swarm attacked your city I hope you're
not squeamish as this might get a little
gross imagine a massive cloud of shadows
coming over the hill covering an area of
40 by 60 kilometers with darkness each
square kilometer of that monstrosity is
packed with 150 million locusts oh I can
feel them crawling all over me in this
whole video it's estimated that a small
swarm of locusts can eat as much food
every day as 35,000 people big shots in
the locust community such as the desert
locust have figured out this whole
strength and numbers thing they realized
that the more buddies you have around
the less likely you are to be eaten what
this means is those locusts are laying
1,000 eggs in every square meter of
ground allowing the newborns to join in
on the feast and moving together as a
massive hungry unit and its next stop is
your hometown the first thing to go
would be the green areas any gardeners
in the audience can say goodbye to their
plants flowers fruits vegetables it's
all locust food now as for everyone else
well I hope you're not hungry parks
would no longer be green as the locusts
would consume all the leaves flowers and
fruits they even eat bark
imagine taking a stroll down the barren
husk that used to be Central Park and if
your city has a lot of nice nature areas
I've got some bad news for you the swarm
can last for months if nothing is done
to stop them outdoor food markets would
become a thing of the past as the swarm
would begin a hostile takeover you
wouldn't want to leave your home as the
streets would be covered wall-to-wall
with these little beasties but what if
they try to break in
you'd have to lock down your place
sealing all the cracks the swarm could
get through and just because a swarm of
locusts can't eat up a living human
being doesn't mean you're out of danger
locusts grasshoppers and cockroaches are
common causes of allergies when it comes
to locusts they're hormones and
pheromones the scales that come off
their wings and cuticle and increased
amounts of dust can cause a spike in
allergies so is there any chance we
could prepare for a plague of locusts
well if a locust swarm came to a big
city in the United States or Europe it's
hard to say whether we would be prepared
for it or not if we did catch a lucky
break and were warned of the oncoming
swarm we could begin a mass spraying of
chemicals and pesticides over green
spaces that would kill the locusts when
they arrive a biological control for
locusts is a fungus called mannerism it
acts like a natural pesticide and kills
the locusts from the inside
it's not a sure thing though as the
fungus is specific to the insect and
doesn't have a guaranteed kill rate so
what the heck are we supposed to do is
there anything that can save us
well maybe ducks yeah you heard me
ducks releasing ducks is one way that
people are suggesting we curb locust
swarms locusts are a delicious treat to
water birds and they'll eat more than
2-hundred locusts each day but then we
would have a huge amount of ducks
running around well they saved the city
I guess will erect statues of them now
you brave valiant ducks while this
scenario isn't really that plausible
experts think that as global warming
continues locust swarms will migrate to
more urban areas in search of food
in 2020 locusts have been seen in urban
areas of rajasthan india which is
extremely unusual to say the least
they were also reported in April which
is months ahead of their usual arrival
time we probably didn't need another
problem to show us why climate change is
bad but here it is locust swarms will
continue and they'll get worse as the
climate continues to heat up the locusts
will expand their range and the
increased droughts will bring them
together and spark the insatiable
appetite that leads to swarms glad
that's over
let me tell you I am glad to be done
with all this bug talk and
it's the cicadas what if you were
attacked by a swarm of cicadas well
that's a story for another what if
[Music]